[Music]
so
hey good morning everybody uh as
mentioned my name is angelina fabro
i live in vancouver british columbia
canada
um sunny vancouver it's actually not
very sunny
um and i work for a company called steam
clock software and for the last couple
years i've been building
mobile applications for native for
phonegap i've used objective-c a lot of
javascript
we've also done a couple web apps and i
work with some some pretty talented and
awesome people there
but if you talk to me yesterday you got
a bit of a spoiler and that's that
i'm joining mozilla in early june to be
working on firefox os
so that is what i do
[Applause]
the web is actually my my first love
i've been making websites since i was
really small my first one was on angel
fire
um which i mentioned sometimes and uh it
was about dolphins and all it was was
basically animated gifs of dolphins so i
like to think i've come
a little a little bit farther since then
so a little bit about me
um i am not a beginner at programming
um but i don't i'm not an expert like i
don't consider myself to be an expert at
all
um and so this talk is actually about
trying to become an expert as
someone who considers themselves an
intermediate developer we have a lot of
resources and a lot of initiatives to
get people started programming and to
cater to beginner programmers
and until the last year or two it was
actually really hard to find
articles and tutorial bits
for people who are intermediate
developers who think oh you know
i don't know i'm writing code but how do
i make it better
you know and so that's a little bit
about what this talk is about
so the first things first let's get a
few cognitive biases out of the way
because i run into these sorts of ideas
whenever i'm i'm teaching
or presenting or when people come to me
and they like sort of secretly disclose
that they
feel a bit insecure about their
programming you are not special
none of you no neither is anybody else
so that's okay we're all on the same
page i know your mom told you this when
you were a kid but this is actually a
motivational anti-pattern it works one
of two ways
either your mom tells you that you're
totally special and you've got all this
natural talent with the violin and then
maybe like you don't practice
and then all the other people who do
sort of catch up and you don't feel so
special anymore
um or uh you know you think that maybe
if someone else was told they're special
maybe you're not special and so there's
some like disparity between you and the
special people
often the people we think who are
experts we think there's something very
different about them from
from where we are um and so what i
wanted to say is that nobody is born
with natural talent there are no natural
born programmers
and whenever i say this people get
really really emotional about this
and i mean really emotional probably
because their mom told them that they
were special
or probably because if they are a good
programmer they like to pretend that
they're special and that there's some
natural talent
and there's a whole body of research out
there you are all smart individuals so i
will leave it up to you to
to do your own research and take a look
there is an interesting book called
outliers by i think malcolm gladwell i
really hope i got that right
that discusses this topic at length now
um
you are the result of many complicated
interactions um
some of those things that can make you
seem like a natural usually have to do
with your uh
early childhood education the one thing
that people like to glom onto really
quickly is genetics and say like oh well
you know maybe there's
like a gene for programming or a gene
for logical thinking and i'm pretty sure
that there are probably genes that we
can
identify i mean i know there's at least
a few snps identified for
non-verbal intelligence for example but
it's not that simple
our understanding of genetics has come a
long way in the last 10
20 years and really the focus now is on
epigenetics the environmental pressures
that affect gene expression because even
if you have like the predisposition to
uh you know unfortunately have cancer
you may not necessarily have cancer if
you know uh if you take care of yourself
if the environmental pressures aren't
there
and so it's a little bit nebulous to say
that uh genetics are deterministic
because they just they just really
aren't
um also your early childhood exposure to
logical thinking whether or not you had
that
um early childhood practice of these
logical skills and the early framing of
your relationship to logical thinking
a lot of people like myself who grew up
in a fairly well semi-rural area and
didn't have a lot of
positive programmer role models like you
know we were sort of told that
you know if you like math and you like
programming well that's never going to
go anywhere why do you bother with those
computers and some people
you know get framed really early that
like you know math is going to be too
hard for them or program is going to be
too hard for them
well i'm here to tell you today that
nobody is a natural
and um sorry that's just another jeff
about people not liking the logic of it
they feel like they're special um so
your feelings don't matter here um
in spite of popular beliefs there's no
one thing that you're destined to do
purpose doesn't happen to you any more
than love does these things evolve when
you commit yourself fully to something
or someone and make the decision to work
through the muck
so i wanted to say that yes i mean
programming and math and logical
thinking
can be a hard thing but that every
single person in this audience
and their kids and their friends and
anybody you meet is capable of
programming
and there's so much bloody problematic
framing of this topic that it drives me
up the wall
in 2006 jeff atwood posted a
post i guess uh he posted he made a post
about
a academic study and i put that in
quotes because while it was put out by a
academic institution
anybody who's had any training in you
know anybody's gone and done a little
bit of grad school anybody who's been
involved with cognitive science and the
behavioral
sciences and done research design will
read that paper and laugh
because the research design was very
poor the sample size was very small
and what this study was trying to say
was for
students that come into our programming
courses at our university
we can give them a test and we can tell
you or sorry we can predict
how well they're going to do with the
course and we can then separate
programmers from non-programmers
but that's really problematic because
the way people interpreted this is the
way the media often interprets things
and that's very sensational
and they started saying like oh we've
got a test now to tell
you know natural programmers from from
program you know from non-programmers
and i was like well
no all this says is that someone can
tell how well someone's going to do
based on how they teach a course about
programming and also
only considering the knowledge and
experience they have with logical
thinking up until that point which you
just don't know anything about
maybe somebody you know didn't have a
good relationship with math in school
maybe someone else grew up with parents
who were scientists and they just
love the stuff and so i really i really
think you should
take all that stuff with a grain of salt
because it's it's often framed in
like i say a very problematic way um so
yeah so nobody's special
and experts are not born with any
natural talent so
you know that's out of the way and
that's actually really awesome
um it's actually really empowering
because that means that any of you have
the capacity to take from where you are
as a programmer
and move towards expertise and move
towards mastery and feel a lot more
confident
about the things that you do in your job
or in your side projects
so if you practice if you practice
logical thinking and if you practice
programming a lot
and you manage to absorb enough of the
you know vast amount of domain knowledge
is out there
you too will become an expert
so that's pretty pretty awesome so then
how do you know
that you're not a beginner um
so clue number one i think is that you
can use the fundamentals
in any language so by fundamentals i
mean your basic control structures like
loops
uh if else statements um know how to do
like variable assignments i know how to
do some really basic operations and what
the what the main operators are in a
language
if you if you can kind of sit down with
a new language and get out
a hello world um or make a very small
app without having to know the nuances
of a language or framework
i think that you are a little bit beyond
being a beginner
clue number two you are comfortable
writing code from scratch
when people are beginners there's
definitely a pattern of they grab like a
third-party library
like maybe jquery as an example and
they're like oh wow i can do so much
cool stuff with jquery
but a lot of the time they'll like put
jquery in and then they'll just put in a
plug-in and then not touch it
i mean that's not really the same as
programming right
um so i would say that uh you know
someone who's a beginner or just beyond
being a beginner
is uh comfortable writing code from
scratch and not just
editing or gluing together the pieces
that they find
and and just to be perfectly clear that
is an important step like just being
able to like get into the code and try
reading it and edit it and play with it
and copy and paste a little bit
that's actually an excellent
transitional skill to becoming a better
programmer despite the fact that
a lot of people are really against that
i think that that's perfectly fine for
beginners
so if you're not a beginner you're
probably comfortable at least writing
some code from scratch whether it's a
couple functions or a whole
you know like writing all your code to
make your single page application work
uh clue number three that you're not a
beginner uh when you do use something
like jquery you peek inside because you
want to know how it works you may not
necessarily understand
all the things that are in there but you
are getting curious and you want to know
like
you know what's what's going on like how
does how does this iterator work how
does
uh you know how does this selector stuff
work and you start getting in there and
even if you don't necessarily understand
all of it you're at least trying to
and number four you may feel like your
code is mediocre and
you don't really know what to do about
it and this is a really interesting one
because people will not talk about this
topic openly
at events that i teach and talk at but
they'll come to me
personally later on and they'll tell me
and it's very interesting because uh
there's no real like trend about like
gender or ethnic background or anything
like that
it's literally like all sorts of people
be like hey so
i mean i i think you're good at
javascript they'll say
so i feel really mediocre i feel like
there's all this pressure for me to be
really good
really fast because it's a community of
really smart people and i'm like
i feel that i feel you i know them feels
um and so if you have that feeling
you're not alone
and uh you know so okay so those are
some ways that you know that you are not
a beginner
well how do you know that you're not an
expert right i mean if you're not a
beginner i mean maybe maybe you're an
expert
clue number one you don't quite grok all
the code you read
including comments so maybe you do get
into the jquery source and maybe there
are some comments but you still don't
really understand what they're doing
with bind and you know that there's
these things called call and apply and
you don't understand why there's like
two versions of what seems to be doing
the same thing and
and you start like exposing yourself to
some more um higher level concepts this
way
and so if you don't quite understand all
those things you read probably
probably you're not quite an expert
clue number two is that you can't
explain what you know
some people like to argue with me that
there are plenty of competent developers
that are awesome but you know can't for
the life of them explain
their methodology or their practice or
what they're coding to someone else
i think that this is a big problem and
even if you are
you know you know further on other
avenues of expertise like maybe you do
understand bind and call and apply for
example
but you can't explain what you know to
someone in a patient and clear way
that's a shortcoming and you need to get
better at that because programmers need
to be able to communicate and
disseminate knowledge between one
another
and with their teams that they work with
and so clue number three uh you aren't
confident debugging
this one for me like took a long time
like for me to actually really get into
the debugger in like chrome and then
when i'm working with objective c and nx
code and stuff like that and to develop
like sort of
um a mental model of how i could solve
various problems with different
debugging strategies rather than just
doing this
um you know i throw in some console logs
all over the place especially you know
when i started using
node i was a bit of a late adopter to
note and i started realizing i was like
oh
this is why i need callbacks okay um
i like that he just kind of stopped
right there
and then clue number four is you rely on
references too much
so um it's really interesting
that uh most of us who are employed as
software engineers or web developers or
whatever your title is you're writing
code all day
probably you do have a tab open in your
browser that
is a language reference or a api
reference of some sort because to
memorize all of the stuff
is kind of crazy and these things are
changing constantly too
but i think that you should be writing a
large amount of your code for example
particularly vanilla javascript in this
case
without necessarily needing to refer to
a reference i mean if you need to once
in a while
then that's fine but i mean you should
probably aim to write as much
with as little reference as possible and
the reason for this is just that you
will probably
accomplish more honestly you won't be
stopping and getting derailed and you
can write code with confidence when you
know and you've internalized those
little bits
so if this describes you if you are not
a beginner and you are not an expert
welcome to the ambiguous zone of
intermediateness you are not alone
i am there with you um and so from going
from there
uh what does the curriculum for mastery
actually look like
and also what makes a great programmer
and let's start with that second one
so it really depends who's asking and
these this is a little bit of a quote
written by a gentleman named ed weissman
who's writing i really really love he
is um well i know he's definitely older
than i am but he's got something like 30
or 40 years of experience maybe more
than that in programming
and he's written actually a really
interesting ebook that's great for
programmers of all levels but
particularly if you're
uh starting out if you just google ed
weissman you'll be able to find it
and i read this book and it just it
really it really got to me in a in a
good way
um because he answered a lot of sort of
ideological questions about the field of
programming that uh i'd been asking
myself
and and questioning like do i wanna do i
wanna keep doing this short answer yes
um so uh who who is a good programmer it
depends who is asking
to a project manager the programmer who
hits every deadline regardless of
quality
is a good programmer to the customer the
programmer who solves the problem the
fastest
is a good programmer to the business
owner the programmer who makes them the
most money
is a good programmer and to the junior
programmer the best mentor
is a good programmer and to another
programmer the program that they are
most likely to wanted to go to battle
with
is a good programmer so what do i need
to learn
to be an expert and like how do you how
do you even do that
um you know what what do you do you want
to feel unstuck so i'm going to give you
some suggestions here and a little bit
of
ideas for materials so that you too can
transform yourself from being
intermediate into
being an expert um so suggestion number
one
please ask why obsessively short of
existential angst
like all the time i mean i'm talking
specifically about code right now but i
mean like just in general
with your life i mean you can ask
yourself like why did i choose eggs
benedict this morning
um or uh why did why did i choose more
better example
why did i choose to use jquery like why
why did i want to do my
um why did i why did i choose like
twitter twitter bootstrap is because i
i'm uncomfortable in the front end
why did i choose node.js to do all my
server stuff i mean aside from it's
really cool
everybody in this room probably really
likes it but like why did you make that
decision why did you use
express as your as your framework for
your routes and all that
so ask why obsessively to the point
where you annoy yourself
it will give you a tremendous amount of
self-awareness about the choices that
you're making when you're doing
development
so number two i really think that you
should teach or speak at an event
there's this illusion that if you're
standing up here that you're an expert
i like to think like i say i'm on my way
to being an expert but i'm definitely
not an expert the only thing you need to
come up here and speak
is an idea about something that you've
made and like the previous presentation
where remy was showing
his experiment that's a perfect example
if you've done something like that you
need to tell people about it and share
the knowledge that you have with others
and what happens when you're uh you know
teaching or speaking at an event is
that you get to uh sort of formalize and
sort of
make the ideas that you have about what
you've worked on a little bit more
concrete if you can communicate those
effectively you probably know the area
pretty well and when it comes to
teaching i teach at
ladies learning code and i also do some
stuff for simon fraser university
um and that is super enlightening
because
it's a really good reflection on the
kinds of assumptions you make about
your own ability for example at ladies
learning code i get people asking me
questions like
well okay i've sort of worked ahead in
the slides and now i have this piece of
code that i want to reuse
should i copy and paste it and i'm like
no you shouldn't do that you need
functions
and people will often add or ask really
really compelling questions that cause
you to realize oh i actually know
a lot more than i thought about
programming so i also suggest working
through a suggested curriculum
of books this is from john resig's
website that he's had up for a little
while called
learning advanced javascript and if you
can go through this this was sort of
like a proposed curriculum for advanced
javascript
which eventually uh evolved itself into
this book
the secrets of the javascript ninja
which i think has a samurai on the front
um and this book is really fantastic for
me to read because
i keep going through it pardon me i keep
going through it and
realizing there's a lot in that book
that is totally rehashed for me and i
already know
but there's a lot of stuff in there i
don't know so reading a book like this
that has a comprehensive
um sort of outline of topics of mastery
for javascript
will help you reaffirm what you know and
what you don't know and that's a really
good feeling like to read through a book
and be like yeah i got that
or to discover that like you had no idea
about function memoization that totally
blew my mind for example
experiment recklessly the code doesn't
care this is suggestion number four
the code does not care how old you are
who you are where you came from or
anything like that
nobody needs to see your code till you
push it up to the branch that you need
to push it to
or until you need to show it to someone
else for code review so experiment
be be reckless like do silly things just
to see what happens the code
it's just code it's inert until you give
it purpose so number five
um you should have opinions if you're
progressing towards
i guess an expert level of understanding
and knowledge you will probably
naturally start to have opinions
um although it's really important to
remember that when you're having
opinions that uh and you're trying to
sort of
cooperate with people that um you're
gonna run into people that you disagree
with
and there's a little song that i like on
the internet about that and it goes
something like this
it's okay to not like things but don't
be a jerk about the things you don't
like
so just internalize that please um and
i really like this one by emily
everybody we're having opinions on
things again
don't forget to state yours as fact or
as you don't get to play so just you
know
be be reasonable and also accept that
you could be wrong and that being wrong
is actually fantastic because there's an
opportunity for learning there so number
six
seek mentorship if you're here you're
probably already in the right place but
also in your workplace
one of the most fantastic things about
working at steam clock software is being
able to turn around to alan pike who's
one of the co-founders
and be like hey so i have this
ridiculous sounding javascript idea and
or question and then we just go to the
whiteboard and talk about it with like
no
you know weirdness about it like i know
that it's not always easy for some
people
in their uh jobs to do that but if if
you can't do that in your job try and
find another job where you can do that
you will become a better programmer
suggestion seven program a lot
suggestion eight
stop [ __ ] programming sometimes you
need breaks okay you like to think you
can code 24 7.
your brain doesn't work that way it
needs it needs breaks that's why when
you like are trying to fall asleep or
you're in the shower bam you'll know how
to fix that bug you need time away from
the computer
um suggestion nine write javascript a
lot suggestion ten
write in another language for a while
actually i mean you should probably be
writing mostly in javascript
but if you get outside your comfort zone
a little bit and start comparing
javascript with other languages you'll
find
that there are a lot of little nuances
to javascript that maybe you didn't know
and programming in another language
exercises the brain much in the way that
learning another
uh spoken language would in a sense um
number 11 think like a programmer when
afk people think i'm really weird for
optimizing my route when i go to ikea
and figuring out like the optimal way to
get through it as fast as possible
and that might be silly to some of you
but that's great like you should be
doing those sorts of thought exercises
as much as you possibly can because
that exercises the logical part of your
brain which is largely well that's what
you need for programming
and suggestion 12 know what good
feedback is and reject all
else it turns out that some people
aren't very happy with themselves and
they will take it out on you
so sometimes on the internet someone
will reply to your question or your post
and honestly like if they're not being
constructive and they throw in epithets
or they say something mean
tone is a bit of a variable one then you
know honestly
if you're not getting anything
constructive out of it probably it's a
waste of your time there will be someone
else who can give you constructive
criticism
so just know how to differentiate
between good feedback and troll feedback
the last one really that's a suggestion
is to break free of imposter syndrome
um it just so happens that if you write
code you are a programmer
the end relative of your ability people
that come out of the beginner javascript
courses that i teach
tell me that they want to be quote a
real programmer one day
and i asked them like okay well are you
writing code yeah no i'm writing code
every day
okay great you're a programmer no no
angelina i want to be a real programmer
and what they're actually trying to say
is that they want to be good
and so hopefully if you are someone at
home that gets to see this video and
maybe you are in this nebulous
intermediate zone
you will understand that yes you are a
programmer and your desire to want to be
good
is good and you will get there i promise
if you do some of these things
and i want you to fall in love with your
process i want you to fall in love with
the balance between writing code and
taking breaks i want you to fall in love
with the process of like
you know arguing your point and then
taking the opposite position because
this sort of variety is what's going to
help you grow as a person it's going to
expand your self-awareness
and hopefully make you a better critical
thinker about your programming
and so this is the end of my
presentation thank you wonderful humans
for inviting me to share
this has been javascript masterclass and
i'm angelina favre you can follow me on
twitter at
uh angelina magnum questions by the pool
so that's it
you